PEOPLE MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE,
MANY OF THEM THROWN IN JAIL.
OHIO CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN IS
WITH US.
SARA CARTER IS HERE WITH US.
AM I MISSING ANYTHING HERE?
>> YOU ARE NOT.
THE CENTRAL PLAYER IN THIS
ENTIRE DRAMA IS THE GUY YOU
IDENTIFIED, PETER STRZOK.
THE FIRST BATCH OF TEXT
MESSAGES, HE TALKED ABOUT THE
INSURANCE POLICY IN CASE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE MAKE
DONALD TRUMP PRESIDENT.
THIS LATEST BATCH, HE TALKS
ABOUT UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
CODE NAME THEY HAD FOR THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
4 MINUTES AFTER THAT TEXT
INVESTIGATION HAD LEAKED TO
IMPEACHMENT.
IF THAT DOESN'T GO TO THEIR
ENTIRE MOTIVE, THEIR ENTIRE
PLAN, WHAT THEY HAD IN STORE,
AND THE ANIMUS THEY HAD FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT DOES?
AS YOU POINTED OUT IN YOUR
INVESTIGATION.
HE WAS THE GUY WHO CHANGE THE
EXONERATION.
>> Sean: ARE WE GOING TO GET
IN OTHER WORDS, WE DON'T GET --
>> WE SEE THE BUILDING.
YOU CAN SEE A BUILDING.
WE CAN SEE A BUILDING A AMONGST
THE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
200 MEMBERS OF CONGRESS HAVE
READ THAT MEMO.
200-0 IN FAVOR OF RELEASING IT
BECAUSE THIS IS THE KIND OF
THING THAT IS SO WRONG.
WHEN THE FBI SAYS THIS, THE FBI
IS INVESTIGATING YOU AND YOU
LOSE IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS OR YOU
DELETE EMAILS OR LOOSE TEXT
MESSAGES --
>> Sean: I WILL BE IN JAIL.
BRING ME THE CAKE.
LET ME GO TO SARA CARTER.
IT HAS BEEN ALMOST A YEAR SINCE
YOU AND JOHN SOLOMON BROKE THE
STORY ABOUT THE WARRANTS AT
TRUMP TOWER, THE INVESTIGATION.
LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
WHERE ARE WE GOING?
I HEAR THIS IS JUST THE TIP OF
THE SPHERE.
APPEARANCE BECAUSE
THIS IS JUST THE TIP OF THE
SPEAR.
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE PETER STRZOK
AND LISA PAGE, BUT THEY WERE
REPORTING TO SOMEONE.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON THEM, WITH
GOOD REASON, BUT THINK ABOUT THE
McCABE, WHO IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH TEXTING TO OTHERS,
FBI.
NOW WE KNOW McCABE IS LEAVING
IN MARCH.
THERE IS SO MUCH MORE TO THIS
STORY.
THE UNMASKING AND DIRECTOR
BRANDON OF THE CIA.
>> Sean: SAMANTHA POWER,
UNMASKING 300 PEOPLE.
GREAT.
WHAT IS THAT POWER COME FROM?
GOWDY THAT SOMEONE SIGNED THOSE
UNMASKING'S AND HER NAME.
TO BE WHAT I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHO.
AMBASSADOR AND WERE UNMASKING
AMERICANS.
FUNDAMENTALLY, DAN BONGINO, THIS
FIVE MONTHS GAP.
THIS IS SO MUCH BIGGER THAN THE
WATERGATE TAPES.
FIVE MONTHS, THE MOST CRITICAL
TIME.
MERRICK.
WITH YOUR EXPERIENCE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SECRET SERVICE
AND THE NEW NYPD, ARE WE ABLE TO
RETRIEVE THOSE FORENSICALLY?
I DON'T BELIEVE THEY ARE LOST.
>> LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
I'M WILLING TO PUT MY
CREDIBILITY BEHIND US ON YOUR
SHOW TONIGHT.
THOSE MESSAGES AREN'T LOST.
I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THIS IS
SOME KIND OF CANARY TRAP TO OUT
THEM AGAIN.
WE'VE SEEN THIS PATTERN BEFORE
PITFALLS INFORMATION PUT OUT
THERE TO CATCH PEOPLE LEAKING
INFORMATION.
WE SAW IT IN THE
STORY.
WE ALSO SOUGHT WITH THE MIKE
FLYNN STORY.
LET ME SAY SOMETHING HERE.
THAT FIVE MONTH PERIOD BACK HIS
AND IMPORTANT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE THE LOGAN ACT CONFEDERACY,
OR WHAT I'VE BEEN CALLING A
REVERSE ENGINEERING OF A CRIME,H
REVERSE ENGINEERING OF A CRIME,P
REVERSE ENGINEERING OF A CRIME,E
REVERSE ENGINEERING OF A CRIME,S
REVERSE ENGINEERING OF A CRIME,I
REVERSE ENGINEERING OF A CRIME,N
THE DOJ AND FBI.
LISTEN TO ME, MAKE THE MISTAKE
OF THIS.
DONALD TRUMP WAS SET UP.
THIS WAS A STING OPERATION THE
ENTIRE TIME, AND AT THIS LOGAN
ACT CONSPIRACY THAT HIT MIKE
>> Sean: I BET MY LIFE ON IT
THAT WAS A TRAP.
IT WAS ILLEGAL TO INFORMATION
THEY HAD.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO GET THE
MEMO?
WHEN DO WE GET IT?
>> I THINK SOON.
WE HAD THAT FIVE-DAY PROCESS.
I BELIEVE THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
WILL GIVE US THE THUMBS UP RIGHT
AWAY.
IF THAT PASSES THE COMMUNITY
WITH A MAJORITY VOTE, I THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL SAY LET THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE IT.
>> HE DEFINITELY BROUGHT UP WHAT
I WAS HEARING AS WELL.
THERE WILL BE A VOTE NEXT WEEK.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN TOLD.
I'M SURE HE WILL ALLOW THAT TO
GO PUBLIC.
>> Sean: I HEAR THERE'S A LOT
MORE EVEN COMING BEHIND THAT
MEMO.
DO BOTH OF YOU GLEAN THAT?
>> YES.
I THINK THERE WILL BE MORE
MEMO'S, SEAN.
HERE'S THE OTHER THING I THINK
IS IMPORTANT.
WHY ROD ROSENSTEIN WHEN HE
TESTIFIED JUST LAST MONTH, WHY
DIDN'T HE TELL US THEY WERE
MISSING TEXT MESSAGES?
>> Sean: EXACTLY.
BRING HIM BACK.
DOES HE EXTEND THAT FISA WARNED?
DID HE EXTEND THAT?
>> I CAN'T GET INTO WHO DID
WHAT.
I CAN'T GET INTO THAT.
>> Sean: MY GUESS IS HE DID.
>> ROD ROSENSTEIN CAME AND
TESTIFIED IT WAS ACT ABOUT THE
TEXT MESSAGES.
THAT WAS THE DAY BEFORE HE
TESTIFIED WAS WHEN WE GOT THE
FIRST BATCH OF THE STRZOK TEXT
MESSAGES.
THE FBI TURNED THEM ALL OVER.
>> Sean: HE WENT INTO PAUL
RYAN'S OFFICE BEGGING NOT TO
RELEASE ANY OF THIS.
THAT CONSTITUTES THE METAL.
DAMME AND GINO LASSWELL.
>> DON'T DISCOUNT THE NAME
GIANCARLO EITHER WITHIN THE DOJ.
HE KNEW IT WAS GOING ON HERE IN
IN -- THIS IS THE CONNECTION
THAT I TAKE TO THE WHITE HOUSE
ON THIS.
HE LEFT UNDER VERY SUSPICIOUS
CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> Sean: I FORGOT TO MENTION
THAT IN THE TIMELINE.
>> IT IS AN IMPORTANT POINT A
CRUCIAL POINT, BUT I THINK AN
EVEN BIGGER POINT NOW IS THAT
RADCLIFFE WANTS TO INTERVIEW
CALL ME.
INTERVIEW COMEY.
INTERVIEW CARLIN.
WITH THEM.
I THINK WE WILL START TO SEE THE
STORY UNRAVELED.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, AMAZING
WORK ALL OF YOU.